class is with us
in indianapolis hi bless how are you
i'm great yourself better than i deserve
what's up
well um so here's the deal um i'm
currently engaged
uh to my fiance we've been together for
five years
but she has three wonderful children one
of which
has a lot of special needs um the
biggest
issue with us getting married is that
he's on medicaid
and if we get married he loses that so
he loses it due to your household income
being too high
that's correct what do you make well i
make seven a year
what does she make uh she's gonna stay
at home
okay so that's why the kids she has no
income
right now exactly that's correct well
well she
well sorry she does she does she's got
child support and she does get ssi for
him so her monthly is about uh yeah but
i mean as far as the calculation for his
ssi
she's allowed if i remember it's about
three thousand dollars a month
that she can make without canceling out
his ssi
and so by your household income going to
70 it cancels it out
he'll lose the ssi and the medicaid see
ssi and medicare set up for
not special needs they're set up for
welfare
right right for people that are too
broke to eat
but but the problem is is because of his
needs he had he was born with a heart
defect
so his bills get really really really
high
um and i wouldn't doubt that his last
surgery probably broke the millions
do you have do you have health insurance
through your work
i do yes can you not add your family to
it
i could but i i'm not sure how that
would affect uh a pre-existing condition
it's obamacare dude you can add them
okay pre-existing or not you need to you
need to talk to your health insurance
people and your hr benefits and make
sure but i think you can add them
your whole family to your health
insurance plan you make seventy thousand
dollars a year
and this family of uh with three kids
and this lady or your family
and they're going to be taken care of by
your health insurance plan and by your
income
and so they're getting off of welfare
right right right okay that's what it
means i mean i'm not being cold
that's just what it means medicaid is
for people who don't have an income
it's welfare right right and there's not
it's not evil it's not horrible
it's where she was but we're not gonna
not get married and live in the same
house so we can keep her on welfare
right right that's that's that's morally
wrong
so so then so then by us getting married
i can put her
them on my insurance and his medical
condition should be covered in full
or should be it should be but double
check that you don't have to take a
radio guys
that's like you said it's a million
dollar question you don't take my advice
on it you check it out for yourself
but it should be the pre-existing
conditions can be added
under obamacare now now say that it's
not covered in full and we still
wouldn't be able to cover
the difference uh like if there's like a
copay or or
you cover the copay you can handle a
copay
yeah what about like the 70 80 split or
stuff like that
that's the copay okay okay let me tell
you okay insurance has three numbers
health insurance and learn about these
three numbers when you talk to your hr
group okay
okay number number one you're familiar
with is the deductible
right and you pay a hundred percent
until you meet the deductible you know
that right
right right number number two is the
copay and it's typically 80 20. they pay
80
you pay 20 once you've hit your
deductible
the third number is the important one in
this discussion that'll give you a lot
of peace and that's called stop
loss stop loss okay and that's your max
out of pocket what is your maximum
out of pocket and typically it's going
to be
uh who do you work for what kind of
company just don't tell me who but what
kind of company do you work for
i'm a truck driver okay for over the
road or
in town regional regional local okay is
the company a trucking outfit
or do you drive for somebody that's like
a walmart or something like that
uh yes exactly exactly okay so they
probably got good insurance
which means your stop loss your max out
of pocket
is probably in the neighborhood of
10 grand maybe 20 grand
okay and so that if this kid goes in and
has a million dollar surgery you're 80
20 you're deductible everything added up
when it hits that stop loss it stops and
they pay 100 after that
and so if it's a million dollars and you
have a stop loss of 10 000
you pay 10 000 they pay 990 000
and that that's what that's the three
numbers you need to understand and then
the last thing you need to understand
is i'm getting married to a lady who has
a child with some special needs
what uh you know what pre-existing
conditions
are how is that work with our policy
here at work
and let hr tell you that and let them
send you the brochures showing you
in writing that this kid is going to be
covered after three months
or this kid is going to be covered after
a year or this kit is going to be
covered from day one
um somewhere in there is probably what
you're going to find
i suspect you probably can solve this
problem
and that actually is my concern dave
is i i just hear him doing the math in
his head
on this relationship and he's marrying
somebody with
special needs child he's in love with
somebody saying i'm pledging myself to
her
and the kid for better for worse and
those kids
and if at the end of the day before he
pulls the trigger and gets married
if he says well if that just gets too
expensive then fill in the blank
then he needs to get out and back out
and walk away
well i that that's a possible but i
didn't hear that what i heard was i want
to make sure i'm do
i can do my job okay and i don't want to
set myself up where i can't take care of
this kid
i said i'm going to take care of him and
then if it's a million dollars i can't
do it that's exactly right
okay and i will make sure i can do it
okay i i i i'm giving it that's a much
more noble
approach than than that's right that's
okay it could be either way you don't if
it's if it is dollars and cents then
walk
and uh this is the problem though with
the
medicaid ssi the whole welfare system
is it encourages people to not be
married or it disincentivizes people
from
right yeah incur well i mean same thing
the incentive is not to get married
because it screws up everything
and um or it's seen as a forever instead
of a stop gap right
yeah well and you know if you don't have
another way to cover a child that has a
potential million dollar operation
it is forever until you find a way to
cover it so you gotta you gotta take
care of the babies
and but i i'm pretty sure that he can
get this child insured
i might be wrong but i don't think i am
and uh especially if he's working for
a big regional or a big national company
that he happens to be driving truck for
and um they probably have a sweet plan
that would be my guess and even if it's
a little bit expensive do it anyway
right
do it anyway even if it costs you you
know 300
more a month and that hurts a little bit
uh do it right that's good
that's good let's because the family
that is married
and committed economically will
out prosper the family that is shocked
checked up
statistically every time right
economists call it the marriage benefit
it actually causes economic lift to be
married because on
average married people make more than
shacked up people household income
on average nationally and it could be
social economic it could be the
you know what's the cause what's the
effect you can argue that if you want to
but we do know statistically married
people make more
than shacked up people make on average
a lot more throughout their life it's
the marriage benefit that's talked about
and so that's what i want for your
family long term but in order to do that
we have to solve the short-term
potential issue and make sure that this
child is cared for which is a noble
thing
absolutely it is very very good stuff so
um
there is i have never in 30 years of
being on this error shame someone for
being in medicaid
and that includes a nursing home for
medicaid but i will tell you
that when you have the opportunity to
not be in it it is your calling to not
be in it
so when you have the opportunity to buy
long-term care insurance so you don't
have
welfare nursing home which is the only
way the government pays for it is
medicaid
then you should do that you should do
that you should take care of yourself so
somebody else doesn't have to take care
of you
right that's pretty basic personal
responsibility stuff and i've said that
all along